♪ (ROCK MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
Stay where you are, Smith.
I knew it was fucking
too good to be true.
Fuck! Fuck! Ah, fuck.
Fuck!
Hey, everyone.
My name is Peacemaker
and if it wasn't clear
by the outfit,
I am a genuine superhero
and protector of peace.
And I am Agent Emilia Harcourt.
I'm here to provide
a factual account
of Christopher Smith's history
with our agency
because we know
that he won't be doing that.
♪ (MUSIC CONTINUES) ♪
This whole thing kicked off
when Amanda Waller came to me
and asked me to lead
a super team to save the world.
Close. Not exactly.
The aforementioned super team
was comprised
of highly dangerous prisoners
serving time at Belle Reve,
Smith included.
For the duration of the mission,
I was in the communications hub
with John Economos
and Amanda Waller.
Smith was not the leader.
Robert DuBois, aka Bloodsport,
was put in charge of team two.
Thank God.
PEACEMAKER:
My team was the real team.
Team one were a bunch of losers,
disloyal and scared shitless.
I think there was even
a fucking ferret or something.
He was a weasel, but yes,
team one was a decoy,
sacrificed
for the larger mission.
That's not to say my team
didn't have its challenges,
the biggest challenge being this
jackass with a stupid accent
whose biggest accomplishment
was figuring out
how to hide a flame thrower
in his scuba suit.
Yeah, it was
a dick measuring contest
between Smith and DuBois
from moment one.
The exact number of friendlies
they took out is...
still confidential.
Fuck that guy!
We can check the tape
and see who took out
more guerrillas--
soldier guerrillas,
not monkey gorillas.
Okay, monkeys
would have been better.
You killed allies.
I'm not saying
you should kill monkeys.
I don't want you to--
please don't go kill monkeys.
Okay? Don't confuse me here.
Anyway, we reach our target,
a lab called Guggenheim
or Heineken or something.
EMILIA HARCOURT: Jötunheim.
(DRAWN OUT) Jötunheim.
PEACEMAKER: And inside,
we uncovered this alien starfish
that was captured in space.
And this starfish, by the way,
can control minds.
Pretty fucking dangerous weapon
if you ask me.
Unfortunately, Flag went rogue.
PEACEMAKER:
Rick Flag thought the truth was
more important than peace.
I can't let you do that,
Colonel.
Excuse me?
Let me be clear.
Nothing is more important
than peace!
Am I happy about what I did?
No.
Peacemaker, what a joke.
PEACEMAKER:
Then Mr. Micro-bullet shoots me
and a building fucking falls
on me, and lights out!
I wake up in the hospital
three months later
and I'm being asked
to save the world... again.
Yeah, obviously we didn't have
a lot of options.
I'm pretty sure we would have
chosen anyone else
if we had the chance.
But the world really is
in imminent danger,
so let's just hope that
Smith can step up to the plate.
I can step up
to any plate you got.
I fuckin' love baseball,
American as apple pie.
So the new mission is codenamed
Project Butterfly.
I'll tell you right now,
if there's a Mothra about to be
unleashed on the world,
I will rip off
its giant ass wings
and fry its body with a massive
fucking magnifying glass!
That is not what
Project Butterfly is, okay?!
I mean,
they can't all be kaijus!
Are we good here?
We have a lot of work to do.
Always fucking around, man.
♪ (ROCK MUSIC CONTINUES) ♪